[Musica]
terra tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su terno
di smau il menu di sul gioco è qualcosa
di fantastico cazzo prima vedere come
funzionavano attivino per capirci un
secondo qualcosa e vi avverto legale se
non l'avete se non lo conoscete ancora
preparatevi perché è assurdo cazzo vabbè
ragazzi andiamo su play avete provato a
vedere come era questo ovviamente
ragazzi sto gioco consisterebbe in
questo non ora ecco è perfetto e ti
passa una macchina sopra il braccio come
se niente fosse
credo ragazzi che l'obiettivo se non ho
capito male sia quello di farsi più male
è possibile madonna il disastro o che
perfetta perché la macchina se ne sta
andando a [ __ ] da sola e per la cosa
[ __ ] ragazzi che poi potete pubblico
gesto col suo addio no vabbè io ho visto
soltanto cazzo come cazzo si fa a fare
un acrobazia con un triciclo
spiegatemelo c'è un asset che bella ma
che ve la posizione è questa c'è ma io
vado bellissima famiglia che è stato
[Musica]
olè olè minchia che però madonna che
botta in faccia
no no cazzo anomica che cos'è sta roba
mano con un camion dei pompieri di
fronte a una rampa pazzesca no come cat
no ragazzi questa bellissima bellissimo
minchia che design non mi dire che mi
cade in testa non mi dire che mi piace
ragazzi ragazze marchio [ __ ] cast dove
vai dove vai fermo per nicchia l'albero
minchia madonna mi ma mi è saltata testa
questa cosa amo questo cazzo di gioco
come cazzo si cambia select level
perfetto chicken che cazzo vuol dire
chicken cos'è sta roba ci vado col
triciclo perché mi sembra da pro c'è una
è passato le macchina ma possono anche
le macchinista opposto fighissimo cazzo
lega per gila ok va bene tutto a posto
se anche mi calmo star tra madonna ma
che figura mai così stronzo oddio non
era proprio esattamente quello che
volevo farlo rientrato nel finestrino si
gioca su dio santissimo ok ok o be nice
come se non bastasse mi è passato pure
sopra fantastico ragazzi stacolma donare
player e meraviglioso macondo cup quando
lo vedete nell'acrobazia così la vostra
tatum e partita una gamba ma non fa
niente ha finalmente un madon neanche in
gta neanche in gta guardalo mica la
macchina è partita voglio io io non ho
fatto io non ho fatto un cazzo è col
motorino e da ed approda pro assurdi se
io riesco a fare una cosa del genere dio
santo ce l'ho fatta
se riuscissimo a fare una cosa del
genere [ __ ] il pullman eccolo lì
lo sapevo lo sapevo che disastro che
cazzo è successo si va ben altra
benissimo grazie grazie mille manco i
negozi muleto come cazzo sono ridotti
madonna che lo cita che velocità
[Musica]
se sono finite in autostrada nel modo
più sbagliato possibile però e capisci
che è una giornata di merda quando un
pullman ti cade in testa è già buona
notte
ciao zio la mia moto mickelson fottuti
la moto c'è ragazzi io vi farei ammirare
con che maestria si sono potuti la moto
beigua guarda come se ne va tranquillo
c'è quello ci ha guadagnato una moto
così a caso haga avete mai visto una
cosa del genere che come cazzo ci
salgono a sopra lei sa che ben che vada
bene con questa mai così ci siamo
ragazzi già possiamo fare non ci posso
principo ci prova e ci fa madonna si si
si si
verso l'infinito è altresì vinchio sono
fatta non ci posso vado al mare disastro
regala reagan sono cadendo non lo sma
donna che alto che porca [ __ ] dove
cazzo è il mio paracadute a macchina
andato a [ __ ] bull tattiche e morbido
aids è grandissimo e tutto a posto
ok
[Musica]
e lui continua imperterrita sì sto per
fare una cosa che non credevo si potesse
parlare da un attimo che voglio provare
ok avete capito penso perché l'avete
vista oddio sismica seccato in piedi se
cado in piedi dove cazzo soprattutto
qualcuno mi dice come cazzo si va a
guidare in questa posizione non so se
ecco infatti la macchina andato a
[ __ ] che kaze ragazza volta
cellophane goalie eccolo quello che
volevo eccolo e sono rimasto dentro
questo significa essere uno stuntman tra
l'altro col culo mezzo di fuori
fantastico devo andare in mezzo alla
strada perfetto fi ragazzi ci siamo
arrivano i pompieri e mettono a posto la
situazione come al solito vai così
bellissimo del teatro madonna e disastro
ok io io non ho fatto un cazzo entrato
nel passato anche il cambio sopra e
tutti sono ok infierisce ancora se
riesco a prendere una macchina magari la
cappotto se grandezza che stavolta
andato decisamente meglio credo dato
polar volano i camion completamente a
caso bellissima ho in mente un suicidio
ragazzi come ultime parole vorrei dirvi
che siete stati fantastici hackett mario
merda l'abbiamo fatta e questa è stata
una vita grandiosa piena di
soddisfazioni e [ __ ] la strada è
che disastro sul parabrezza fantastico
noi sono entrato in galleria prog
minchia che il casinò ho fatto fare
incidenti almeno quello vai vai vai si
si si oh cazzo dici farlo
è impossibile va bene va bene sì certo
qualcos'altro un aereo il carrello
andiamo alla chance dovete morire
adesso ci sono riuscito passato ore ore
col cazzo di triciclo e il carrello a
tentare di impostare questa strada di
merda non è possibile grandis queste
come parcheggio io di solito stato come
cazzo ha fatto con la macchinina butta
su un camion di 200 tonnellate
mica è un proiettile sto cazzo di camilo
allegria
buongiorno lei è tutto a posto senta
bimbi presa la macchina che sono rimasto
a piedi ha dato sfoggio sto leccando il
terreno non si sa perché questo spiega
ancora non ho provata dai così grande
alla è di guerrero faccia lo spaccone
segui guido anche da dietro e ti guarda
lì dove di questo dove di questo tipo
infilare nel culo perdente come cazzo
fatto noto bar bastardo di merda che ha
fatto
non ho poi non è possibile non è posto
che cazzo successo se vado così dovrei
riuscire a friend madonna troppo veloce
questo vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
vai vai vai vai vai bye bye bye bye
madonna che la strada è un'altra
brutto bastardo fermo e allora sei
stronzo forte la macchina sarebbe mia
per ungari seta come lavori dare prova a
battere questa stronzo prova ci si è
certo bastardo e mi abbandoni così
un amico mi ha mai bevuto birra ma
pesante e va beh ma certo che mi superò
se sbanda porca [ __ ]
almeno lui e sobrio e cioè sono sceso
dalla macchina e la macchina pinto alza
la gara è nostra e abbiamo siamo forti
d'accordo ragazzi prova l'ultimo che mi
sembra pazzesco e poi finisco la faccio
un salto solo perché voglio vedere se
riesco a farcela e poi niente se ssa
successo lo continuerò nel prossimo
perché saranno tipo qualche ora che
gioco perché ho bisogno di una pausa ma
ce la posso fare
vai così ma in piani nel traffico di è
bravo bravissimo
è così che ti voglio mica son diventato
una sottiletta fantastico alcuna un
panino ma vero iasi io direi che possono
includere qui perché c'è sto gioco è
pieno di cose pazzesche cioè non ho
parole ma punti però di sicuro perché mi
piace da morire tanto non ho visto
ancora occasioni livelli quindi non vedo
l'ora di vederli e niente ragazzi se io
a dire che possono chiudere qui a chi da
per i prossimi episodi di turbo di smog
di teano tipo qualche salto che volete
che faccia come al solito servito è
piaciuto stato un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook con un
livido tra la transizione sarà il
senatore steve scrivetemi noi ci vediamo
al prossimo video ragazzi